I thought we could all enjoy a little
bit of classical music but revisited in
a more electronic form I actually enjoy
writing music also but the reason I
presented that was to just talk about
the fact that typically when we talk
about visualizations or computers in
general we tend to dismiss anything that
is more than a few years old we want the
latest greatest but then we can find
really some gems in the history of
visualization and speaking of history
what is interesting is that for the
stem-and-leaf plot we just need one
thing the digit the numbers 0 through 9
however we can improve on that in
certain ways by adding some graphical
elements and so from and just mentioning
the numbers from medieval times all the
way to the 14th century the changes were
quite abrupt and many of them however
from the 14th century up to our day on
the digits in our type of scripts the
glyphs are the same so it got to a point
where people were comfortable with it
and what it means is that really it's
effective so as far as graphs and bar
charts we can find some as early as the
1300 nikka ahem in a Latin manuscript
which was printed this is a printed copy
from the 1480s introduced some of these
charts and really it is to talk about it
says latitude didn't boost which really
it's the horizontal movement or the
velocity and acceleration even before
Isaac Newton knew he was considering
these things interesting right but there
are also elements that
our tabular or graphical in or semi
graphical but are not stem-and-leaf
plots so if we look at for example bus
transfers or timetables in general look
like they are arranged a little bit like
a stem-and-leaf plot and even though
Wikipedia might tell you that there are
some stem-and-leaf plots that are
timetables in reality the time at the
stem-and-leaf plot is supposed to be a
distribution plot and the timetable is
not the purpose of it is not that so
it's a little bit different however they
do look similar in fact in one
publication from 1919 we see this chart
and if i zoom in a little bit we'll see
these are numbers and I could have also
add maybe perhaps area charts and we
would have seen perhaps a legend on the
side giving us more detail but we had to
go back and forth back and forth here we
see the numbers directly but again it's
not quite a stem-and-leaf plot and if we
continue over there you go 1946
undoubtedly add a book for engineers
where is basically producing a
transcription table so that's crème
transcription table as columns however
since they are not stacked it's not yet
quite the stem-and-leaf plot and of
course as far as graphical
representation sometimes it's very valid
in fact jockey birthday in 1967
introduced a book that in English is
named semiology of graphics if you don't
have a copy of that I would definitely
recommend it it's a great book and he
introduced some concept of sorting based
on visual cues instead of sorting by
value like by age or x amount of theft
in this case which was the information
that he wanted and then he could see
some kind of linear relationship across
so sometimes it's worth it but we can
also go overboard when we are doing
graphics roberto bochy in 1968
introduced this
on top of graphical rational patterns so
this is a little harder to read than
numbers everybody agree all right so I
mean it was an interesting concept but
perhaps taking a little too far so in
1970 in the classroom John Tukey
introduces the stem-and-leaf plot what's
interesting to note is that to this day
it is used in the classroom and as early
as the fourth grade in norcal and i
believe it's starting in the fifth grade
that they introduced them to dis plot if
we continue in 1972 he published a paper
that gave a little more traction to his
concept in are basically a book in Ford
George snedecor some graphic and some a
graphic display and of course in 1975
hoaglin a colleague of his at wrote on
some fortran code to be able to generate
the stem-and-leaf plot but really this
is the book in 1977 that he ended up
publishing with the stem-and-leaf plot
and it also covers the box plot so again
this is kind of one of those a very
important book in the history of
statistical graphs as far as that is
concerned but there was a danger lurking
and what is the danger comes in the form
of something we called a floppy or a
floppy disk yes and why is that a danger
anybody wants to venture a guess well in
1977 the Apple two came out initially it
was with cassette so storing data on
cassette was kind of awkward and nobody
would want to store a lot of information
because you weren't sure you were
getting it back however with the floppy
now you could generate with your
computer pseudo-random numbers and
create large amount of data well big
data for the time right I mean although
it's probably about a hundred K here
still that
and that the democratization of
computers such as a Commodore 64 even
less expensive or in businesses like the
IBM PC with its CG a color display ah
that was basically trouble for
distending leaf plot because it was text
on the console green screen right and at
the most three hundred data point what
do we do beyond that but at the same
time there were some people that were
holding on into the beauty of the design
our understanding robust and exploratory
data analysis mentioned several points
as to why it is so effective and I won't
go into all the details because we went
that time and Edward Tufte also in the
visual display of quantitative
information makes a mention how the
glyph of the digit is so effective and
of course he's a big fan of data to ink
ratio if you're putting ink on paper it
better represent data fact I experienced
that firsthand talking to him and that
was kind of a all right I got this
incredible new plot I'm going to show it
to him and he's going to be like oh yes
this is marvelous and that's actually
not what happened so he said well your
font is horrible what kind of fun are
you using and well the colors wow
they're way too intense you know them
that a little bit and so I was the
message that he gave me so I went back
home and was like okay well I guess he's
right because we are so caught up
sometimes in the technology or whatever
we've been working on that we're
focusing on one aspect but in reality we
have to look at everything so we worked
on that and continued on so if we look
at perhaps a demo right that it's better
than just always talking about these
things first distribution plot I'm sure
you know most of them I won't going to
the detail of the data that I'm
capturing here but basically Medicare
payments for 2012 and
are your typical pandas manipulations
we'll look at a 1 HP HCPCS code which is
94 640 which represents nebulizer
treatment let's see if I can bum the
font a little bit and if we run a
histogram well we have kind of a 90 of
the distribution and it appears that
there were charges from maybe 0 we don't
know for sure all the way to perhaps 400
but we can't really tell right if we
look at other distribution plot perhaps
you're familiar with the rug plot
basically these little lines each line
is an observation and of course when
there are very dense such as on this
side it's hard to actually see the
individual detail strip plot same
concept but there are also distribution
plots that are pretty effective such as
this one from Seaborn that goes into a
bit more detail plus it that allows us
to do secondary graphs such as a perhaps
a KDE in this case or a KDE inner rug
plot combining oh yes perhaps I should
mention the last one the box plot right
another actually as I mentioned John
kekis invention there so this data gives
me a lot more detail but some people
don't like it personally I like it but
what do you do to get from that point to
actually see the data well so the
stem-and-leaf plot allows you and this
is the output of stem graphic here
allows us to see the individual data
point so on the extreme left is the
aggregate its account so basically it's
telling me how many records I got in the
first row up to second row up deterred
ropes on all the way to the top and
saying that I have
900 data point in that little chart here
and I can actually read the individual
values I can also tell you that $40 the
minion right here and that fifty dollar
seems to be a pretty popular payment
that is requested and all of that from
the little distribution plot so let's
dig a little bit deeper into that so
stem graphic is a python module install
from the victory installs them graphic
and if once you install it current
version is zero point three point three
you can also get your help on it on the
package itself or on the individual
functions there's also a command-line
tool lets associated with it and the
command line tool allows me to for
example i'm listing i got win excel file
here i will run stem on the excel file
and stem automatically looked at what's
the first numerical field that is not
looking like an index unfortunately that
one wasn't very exciting but i know for
a fact that there are some dollars in
the seven column so i'll pass at and see
what i can see there and now it goes
from 20,000 all the way to 200,000 of
course i'm on the command line so it's
text but on there are other methods of
our functions available one is stem hist
one is a stem KDE stemline in stem
graphic itself so when i started looking
into data actually i was reading over
last year over the holiday john two keys
book and I was like why is it not used
and I started looking and on the rosetta
code there were like hundreds of
different implementations in every
language you can think of and so that
was the data set here that they were
using it's a list a plain Python list
here and so I decided to see if I could
replicate that and it looked pretty nice
all and of course I decided that I
should be able to change the colours of
the different elements and make it a
little more flexible from that
perspective it also works on synthetic
data or any data really in this case I'm
just generating numpy arrays and the
data here will be rendered in this case
I decided to replace the bar by
underline in orange different color it's
pretty simple I just add a few key words
to do that there's quite a bit of
flexibility or I could do a histogram a
black histogram like this of course now
I've lost my significant glyph which is
the digit so I can no longer see the
exact values but because it also is uh
using my plot live in this case it can
use savefig and save to a PDF SVG PNG or
whatever other format that i would like
what about if I like our and I want to
do my data munging in our well I can do
that too and in this case I just wanted
for the brevity I put it in the same
notebook but it could be in a separate
note book but in this case I'm actually
using our magic from our py 2 and that
way I can pull which I did two things
here right I let me bump the size a
little bit I actually got the data set
empty cars MotorTrend cars classic and I
got just a car weight from that set and
then also I got the whole quake set
which if you've attended the tutorials
yesterday there was one tutorial that
covered that set in particulars I
figured well let's include that one too
and so if I applaud that I actually seen
the multi-modal approach here and again
we have quite a bit of data here we have
actually 900 points here again if I look
at a car wait there was only 32 and
that's because the set only
who's that many but I can clearly see
the min and Max here which are about
1,500 pound and 450 for 24 pounds for
the heavier vehicle so again I can do
some basic and not so basic quick look
at my data this way i can even a i did
mention i would introduce a new
programming language and heard of today
or maybe you've heard of it it's coconut
which is functional programming in
python compatible with python actually
so i can actually use python statements
and do a pipeline in this case I'm just
pushing from this side all the way to
stem graphics so I'm actually sampling a
hundred from this list that's generated
by this here so it's kind of a
convoluted example but just to say that
yeah there's a level compatibility if
you can bring it into your notebook
environment here alrighty briefly on the
design and implementation I just wanted
to mention it looks fairly simple but
when you start looking at how to count
the number of bins and you'll see in the
performance demo why that is important
the number of bins is how many data
points you'll accumulate in each or how
you going to slice and dice your data
and if you don't get it right you can
get from some more than for me
informative visual display or from or to
basically okay this is useless to me so
that's pretty important to look at that
so I took in a hybrid approach based on
the number of points that are to be
counted so for a smaller data set I take
one approach and if you want more detail
it's in the little booklet if you didn't
get a copy of the booklet there's a few
more copies so after the talk feel free
to stop and grab one okay number of data
points this is where
are you're wondering this guy is talking
about 300 data point nine hundred data
point I have a million data point or 750
or 150 million or a billion data points
what can this tool do for me well so
this is where sampling and other
techniques come into play and I won't go
into the detail yet i will continue on
to the next demo and it'll make a little
more sense one thing also also of course
there's you have to consider when you
create a new visualization how I'm going
to inform the reader or the person
looking at this this chart how it works
so a legend that's important to have so
we spend some time thinking about that
well I'm saying we I mean with me
basically so secondary plots also again
because we saw on Seabourn how that can
how convenient that can be in fact you
could maybe in Seaborn maybe have a
normal curve or a double gamma and all
that and compare and it's like oh yeah
this exact same distribution right
persistence so since we are sampling one
of the interesting feature is it maybe
you don't want to do today or wrangling
it handles quite a bit already it
figures the first column it'll take that
little sample would be nice to be able
to save that sample and just have it for
the visual display that I can continue
my analysis from that sample
particularly if I'm talking about a set
that's a billion records I don't want to
have to query death too often and the
default well I mentioned you know ah as
a tough she mentioned Oh font ugly color
too bright so you have to think about
these things performance demo when I say
performance there are many aspects of
performance one is the speed at which
things run but also so I just loaded
700,000 records look at the histogram so
pandas has a very fast histogram it also
has
plot that will by default do it looks
almost like a histogram that's not
sorted so I couldn't in theory may be
sorted and have something useful but
it's also a little slower according to
time it once it's done it'll tell me it
takes about five second / 04 point for
point 37 so that's actually a little bit
better than usual and I actually I'm
running everything off of the little USB
hard disk external just so you know so
now i'm importing Seaborn and we'll look
at the dist plot that we demoed earlier
Oh what's happening should I panic no I
know actually what's going on basically
Seaborn is telling me that there are
values that are undefined right here and
so what I have to do is drop in a before
I actually call the plot itself so if I
didn't know that well I would lose some
time or so and so forth so let's see how
it did hmm it looks like just one bar
there's a little bit of detail here and
I can see the max value but there's not
a lot of information on this screen and
so that's too bad let's see how stem
graphic does first of all it took two
hundred millisecond about the same or
all faster than this plot but let's see
what it did fine for us so the minimum
value is zero the maximum and I Shrunk
the screen so you guys can see here on
the screen but it's 5.26 so on and so
forth million dollars and I can see the
individual data point I can see my
median and so I get really some
informative display with basically
default behavior except for me adding
the random state so i can reproduce the
same graph for every time i do this
presentation and it ran it multiple time
so let's make excel cry 12.5 million
rows New York City yellow taxi trips
data for 2015 will look at just because
this is a live demo and we want that
that much time will just run on one
month so 12 million rows instead of 150
million and so just I have a little
class here to time this by the way if I
were to look at the data true word count
anybody familiar with word count and
while word count does it sting ah WC is
basically just doing that exactly as
giving need a number of lines words and
bytes in that file and it took seven
point six second which is pretty good
for 12 million records right it's a
pretty big file and so if we run stem
graphic on the same data of course I
have to load it in a panda's so it'll
take a while obviously right but what it
will do is it will go through that data
figure out what the minimum the maximum
value how many records are there and
we'll build the graph oh it actually
came back in 17 second tube and so I
knew that so all right so so we did get
a an output fairly quickly now let's
look at the larger data set and that's
the 150 million records I as I mentioned
I've already run this because it takes a
little longer even just looking at a
word count on this and timing it it ran
it a few times and the best time was
four minutes and 50 seconds so that's a
sea program optimized for doing one job
and it took almost five minutes and us
if we loop through the 12 files and just
read them and that's all we do we just
load them into memory and then put in
the next took eight minute and a half
and the last one
stem graphic from disk again running
this now here's what's happening because
it is way more than the RAM on the
laptop it requires 60 gig of ram minimum
actually I was able to load it on one
node that that's 60 40 again it was able
to load all the data for in New York
City 2015 so its bigger than the ram so
pandas will not work so I'm using what's
that didi Tang that I'm using if we go
back at the top import desk data frame
as DD and sewed ask allows me to have a
data frame that's on disk in this case
however even better than this is that I
could also instead of doing read CSV I
could do it from HDFS so if you have a
dupe cluster or basically any cluster
that has HDFS capability or you could
use s3 or so and so forth then you can
actually pull the data and you can
whereas this took six minute you could
actually even enough node make this
interactive and that is pretty
significant of course there are other
visualization tools that are able to
handle very large data Sarah mentioned
data shader I yesterday but again this
is a tool that's very simple to use of
the only difference is instead of using
my pandas dataframe i'm using the dashed
data frame for very large set and stem
graphic knows about that i remember i
said sampling i'll go back to that so in
term of the sampling uh what's happening
there is that task actually does things
all different than pandas in fact if i
could make one change i might suggest a
one change to the code i had to use a
fraction and not the actual number of
samples i wanted and what that means is
i am required to get the count of data
do the division to get the fraction that
I want and pass that to desk and then it
executes Dan because desk is building
just intent and then you have to do
compute to actually
you the thing that you want to do so its
built-in and to stem graphic so it knows
about as i mentioned lists numpy it
knows about data frames and dashed data
frames from that perspective and again
um as I mentioned performance is not
just about the time it takes it's about
how good the tool is I mean if I have to
spend another hour drilling and figuring
out what it's spitting out to me then
that's not really useful but these are
graphs are used on a regular basis and
really um it's very effective one of the
thing that I've built also is that when
it's samples and it gets back and it
calculates the ratio and it's try to
figure out how many rows or in columns
and how it will look if it thinks it's
like no that's not going to be visually
appealing or unusable that means there's
a good chance that the sampling are hit
one of those edge cases right i mean
there's always if you sample enough
times you'll get a sample that's not
really representative of your data it
happens from time to time so what i did
is i just added something very simple
which is a secondary sampling um i would
love to see people try to as their own
functions and try to experiment with
that and see what else can be done from
that perspective so that's a part of the
future work and since I've put
everything on github then you can also
go and help out and try to figure out
there's quite a large to do actually so
maybe a speaking of large need to bump
it up a little bit um again so that
means that you can actually look at the
code try to figure out how it works if
you want or just use it as it is they've
install and you have access to it it's
only tested on Python tree and you might
think why would that guy is kind of like
not the friendly right
just to know that many of the projects
are actually all aligning themselves to
basically start offering within some
months or even a year in certain cases
python3 only and since I had the limited
amount of time to develop this I figured
well i've been using python tree for
exclusively for over a year now I think
it's okay so alrighty so that pretty
much concludes the presentation any
questions from the audience all right
just wait for them microphone so
sometimes there's more than one line
like there's like a blank line that
doesn't have a number next to it yes and
I wasn't quite sure how to interpret
that one that happens yes and so in the
booklet that explains a little bit more
but what it is is that John two key when
when he designed his stem and leaf plot
EDA find from the get-go three different
approach on to this one is the simplest
which is just I have the digit and the
first on the stem I do so stem dot leaf
times the scale I'd say the scale is a
hundred so I have 2.1 times a hundred 21
in the case of plots that are maybe too
squished and you want to gain a little
bit more vertical so this is the number
of bins that a histogram would calculate
in this case what we do is split from
zero to four on the first or if there's
no data it actually just skips it if
it's the first line at the bottom or if
it's the last one at the end and it's 5
and above so 0 2 4 5 and above I mean
529 on the second line there's actually
one more even more split a graph to a
plot and that goes from 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 already this when you go and split
it
what I've found out is that people have
a hard time associating which line goes
which which and so I don't use it much
beyond EDA work so when I'm exploring
data I'm looking at the data i'll use
maybe the split but if I'm publishing
for somebody if it's appropriate if they
actually want to see the number and part
of the future work that I pointed at is
research in perception which is wanting
also research on persuasive power of
text and graphical elements because it's
been shown that if you have a lot of
visual aspects but not a lot of numbers
people are wondering a little bit more
about your data if it's true or what but
if particle financial areas and whereas
if you have a table with a bunch of
numbers or would this looks very serious
so apparently there's there might be a
an impact by having you know visual and
colors and at the same time the actual
numbers on the chart that's an unproven
theory at this point but it would be
interesting to look at
thank you great talk the stem-and-leaf
plot was really designed for type of
graphic representation data it's a
static thing in today's age with
interactive graphics have you thought of
perhaps having just a histogram but if
you mouse over it becomes a
stem-and-leaf and people can see the
data so it becomes more interactive that
way yes actually so I've been talking
with Sarah quite a bit on bouquet and
I've actually been using bouquet for
quite a while also but I didn't feel
comfortable enough weighted when I
started dad which was back in January of
this year to try to do that right away
uh I add some you know more algorithmic
problems to solve the distributed
computing issues things like that but
yeah definitely it's also in on the big
to-do list on the github repo definitely
interactivity would be quite marvelous
for sure thank you for this and when I
look at this I see like a visual
representation of like descriptive like
a descriptive statistics right you've
got your min max you've got your
distribution maybe it's a stand of you
know you can sort of visually see what
you might get in like a descrip you know
like pandas description um but
descriptive that that can always hide
that can hide part of the nuance of a
data like what um what do you like to
combine this with to really get a sense
of your data on what do you think it's
good for what do you think it's not good
for yes okay so first of all and like
transactions and dollars and things like
that tend to have a distribution that it
lends itself well to these things I've
been looking a ton at Medicare data
things like that and you see patterns
it's like it raises questions things
that you didn't expect to find
necessarily it's like why is there such
a peak in this area why this number
shows up so many times this is like not
normal there's something weird there and
for sure it I would want to investigate
more so there are some areas like that
at work
out pretty good um when you have very
few data points I mean less than 30 I
don't think it's worth the effort to or
the time to issues that and there are
data that basically just a table is the
best approach I mean you just have some
numbers that you want to show and that's
the goal then you know might as well do
that but when you do want to again
salaries house prices on so yesterday
there was a tutorial Don and I did on
house prices and you could clearly see
the distribution of the house prices in
Seattle based on the data and it was
fairly informative so right away you can
see these patterns emerging now even
better would be maybe to combine you
know clustering and colors based on
these clusters and things like that
automatically then it would provide even
more information obviously and because
it's a graphical representation then
that should be possible all right I
think if we don't have any more
questions and our time is up let's give
a big hand for France quality all